if you open a shooting range and then
you offer like hey we have you know
handguns rifles shotguns and drive-by
experience
which one where like you're you're in
the passenger side shooting and then
package two you're driving alone and
you're shooting I'm a level two package
three at the very end they take a
picture of you
[Music]
all right so
um radioactive waste was just discovered
at a playground site of a Mich of a
Missouri elementary school sounds about
right radioactive freaking waste how do
you think they got there coming from the
ground or yeah in the ground this isn't
like Aaron Brockovich [ __ ] like
I just think of Julia Roberts in the
movie I've never seen it but I know it's
about oh yeah I saw it but what's it
about
about that so so she is she's an
activist and there's some stuff with the
water and then she just goes basically
door-to-door and she just helps like
people sue for class action yeah yeah
because there was some [ __ ] in the water
and was [ __ ] up people at like kids
and stuff like that and then when they
were complaining they'd be like no
there's nothing wrong because it's giant
like governmental lobbying [ __ ] going on
and she had to just be a hero of the
people am I right yep see [ __ ] you
got it is it that no I don't know I
didn't care either
is it causing bad things because isn't
like radioactivity everywhere like they
told me not to put my phone in my pocket
and it shrinks my balls yeah are they
having something are they having three
mushrooms I got tiny balls have they
gotten smaller yes luckily it hasn't
caused any damage yet but they were just
able to detect it the [ __ ] this story
[Laughter]
so that's the story I think there's the
world dying there's a guy that works at
the power plant
and what what he didn't notice was the
dog that he's been bringing to work it's
been nibbling on the little new keys
[Laughter]
and then the dog digested the Nuki
nuggets and we went to the playground he
took a [ __ ] in the sand oh I need
transfer are you speaking taika right
now no a little bit Nuki nuggets and
[ __ ] in the sand why is there a dog at
the nuclear plant cause [ __ ] bring
your dog to work day he's sad he's just
[ __ ] emotional support animal oh that
makes sense wow right that's pretty good
someone else explained it go ahead
Colleen
I want some more details Ryan go ahead
the only details is that they [ __ ]
Geiger countered that [ __ ] and they were
like wow this is 22 times higher than it
should be so it's off the charts okay so
what are they gonna do I say where in
Missouri it is uh in elementary school
no like I mean like what city that will
make really like change it for you yes
because it could have been Donna
elementary school in Florissant so that
sounds like a small town I bet you like
decades ago they buried nuclear waste in
like these drums that would allegedly
never leak and then surprise maybe x
amount of years later yeah and then it's
just kind of that's like all New Jersey
right
it's not New Jersey right like it's like
the toilet of New York City it might
have just been like let's just throw our
New York City [ __ ] there and then like
decades later oh it's an actual State oh
actually yeah it wasn't one of the first
13 was it I don't know
[Laughter]
I'll try to go in the history
[Laughter]
first 13. he just said it I just know
it's near that [ __ ] you know only about
half backs Pennsylvania so yeah you
actually are right right yeah so back
during World War II they were testing
nuclear bombs and they were kind of
manufacturing them not even in the area
but the waste from those testing things
they dumped up in a by an airport that
was there at the time and where there
was nothing and then it ended up washing
into the creek like years later and that
Creek ended up going by the school
wow so then that collected over time and
then when something's like you know
washing over time leaking from the drum
like you said Yeah so basically what
we're saying is like this one has been
found now but there's probably like 6
000 more sites across the U.S oh dude
it's a [ __ ] scavenger hunt it's
Assassin's Creed for [ __ ] radioactive
barrels basically yeah like when once
it's everywhere is Nevada so so what are
yeah tell tell them about it finally
bring Nevada down a little bit bring it
down a pen go ahead I don't want to
scare it but yeah Nevada specifically
Summerlin is a huge problem with Pahrump
or something no away but I think Pahrump
you if that's where legal process
prostitution is legal right in prompt
why do you know that bar why do you know
that bar because I looked where to stay
away from yes
but that's also what yeah
they do actual military testing there
yeah they do a lot of testing yeah a lot
like booms and stuff yeah so every now
and then a barrel will just pop up I
think so well Lake Mead
like that's where all the murdered
bodies are like slowly just kind of
being discovered murdered body oh yeah
bodies but that's like the drought you
know it's like oh [ __ ] water's lowering
oh [ __ ] those are feet yeah that's
different yeah I mean I mean that's yeah
like I think they found one in a drum I
found out that's called the Chicago
jacket you know that was that what they
call it yeah that's what Dom used to do
right back in the day uh the mob you'd
like put them in a Chicago jacket that
means put the guy in the in a drum and
then fill it up with coffee that's like
you want a new pair of shoes yeah
cement you eat them in the river oh yeah
yeah because I thought that was
something you say when you're rolling
dice yeah
that works by the way both I like that I
liked it he said eat them in the river
they're ahead of their time bro they
invented the Yi
it's a Chicago not just a normal term
yeah just eat that [ __ ] no that is a
huge State and like there's a population
of like 10 000 maybe yeah um there's
probably areas where like no one no
one's gone for decades yeah and which is
probably the government's like hey let's
just bury here have you seen the Fly
Geyser no I haven't seen that do you see
the Fly Guys what the [ __ ] is that just
the craziest thing I've ever seen in my
life it looks like an alien's Dick came
out of the ground it's in Nevada and
it's like green and glowing Fly Geyser
it's called The Fly Guys where is this
at I was trying to go do a photo shoot
there uh up north like uh east of Reno
and I was gonna go do a photo shoot
there and then like some rich
[ __ ] bought it so you can't go
there no more but oh no way a rich guy
bought an alien dick what wait till you
see it that's sick right that was a good
explanation how is this there is this
the three mushroom head you were talking
about sick right that's Nevada oh wow
that's cool you could buy that they look
like a total recall breast milk
is that crazy or what I don't know what
it is man-made though I don't know what
happened oh that's man-made yeah oh
that's what made me think all this oh my
god well then come on no no no no no
it's not not like art not like art
that's like Disneyland Disney I know and
I like art like some [ __ ] let me
show you Big Thunder Mountains
[Laughter]
I think it's like some accident chemical
[ __ ] I don't think oh like somebody put
some illegal substance it blew up like
they put some yeah
shoved it over ground that's what I
thought of this because when when guy
when men buy large plots of land it's to
I feel I always feel like it's the dump
things oh yeah the legally dump things
because they're gonna shoot things on or
just shoot things yeah that's what I
want to do that's what you know Ted
Turner with Montana
is that bad guy can I turn her own TNT
he's the best okay he bought a lot of
them
he married Jane Fonda he bought a lot of
land in Montana where it was public
hunting and fishing and he made it all
Pride he made it all private dude this
doesn't even look real at all so some
guy bought the land there and now you
can't go that's what because we're
literally about to do a photo shoot in
November there and uh and then I started
researching like how to get in there and
there's tours I guess but they're all
booked or shut down I can't get there
and it was bought and like don't quote
me like either 96 or 2006. Oh weird it
looks like Avatar remember
look like a that looks like another
world it looks sick dude wow that is
crazy that's what happens when you dump
nuclear waste you get the Beautiful
colors we should dump nuclear waste
it's like San Clemente has one of the
best sunsets the colors are great
because they've been leaking radioactive
material for decades and then they
finally shut them down I think a couple
years ago oh there's some parts titties
yeah that's a new way to terraform just
shitty ass desert we gotta just dump
nuclear waste what's what's the downside
of having a little you know generational
death but other than that you can go but
you have to be on a supervised
three-hour tour and then the tickets are
like sold out or maybe it's just a
winner it's gone or something I don't
know but yeah it is on private property
not open to public no trespassing that
kind of [ __ ] the cool thing is if you go
that you can drink and drive because on
property there's no laws against it so
you guys know yeah wow but then there's
no fun there's nothing there that is
true you can't hit anything
you can hit one of the the spouts
that's why you go that's why you go
nadeem's Uncle he has he's part of this
club but it's like a private like 40
acre ranch and that's where we went to
go practice drive-bys
because you can't really do that anymore
why do you mean practice drugs like
shooting out of a vehicle we did that
you can't shoot out a vehicle anywhere
else yeah yeah where you're also going
to practice my mom has a we can't go to
[ __ ] like that's gonna bring my car
in and drive up and down the lanes and
[ __ ] ours wasn't like that though we're
in the back of a truck like hunting
birds I'll just drop by
you know what that's a real idea for a
shooting range though Marvel's
practicing humans yeah yeah I wasn't
trying to kill nobody that's a great
idea that if you open a shooting range
and then you offer like hey we have you
know handguns rifles shotguns and
drive-by experience
that gets the non-casual like the people
that are afraid to start shooting guns
yeah I don't want to go to the regular
shame range yeah I want to start at the
drive but you gotta you gotta do koic
they got to take your like info and
stuff you know register it and you're
like no vpns allowed type stuff you know
you could do package one where like
you're you're in the passenger side
shooting and then package two you're
driving alone and you're shooting I'm a
level two package three at the very end
they take a picture of you
yeah you know what you know what would
be a great it would be a great first
course is home defense drive-bys when
fearing for your life
that'd be cool because you had to
justify why you're doing it yeah you
can't be the aggressor right you're
driving away this isn't that the whole
point purchasing it because you can be
the aggressor in this contained
environment yeah but they'll never let
that happen well I guess so I honestly
do I I now have a new goal of making a
lot of money it's like a buy a large
part of land and do the drive-by pop off
that's one of my goals dude dude that'd
be amazing or probably Missouri you
could do it now for sure I mean you go
to that radioactive school no one wants
to go there just buy it yeah go to it's
a great buy opportunity it's like a
hundred thousand years the radioactivity
the Pennies on the dollar right alien
Dick's already off the market we missed
out some states you could buy like 100
acres for like 20 grand or something I
don't know what Texas is like that yeah
like whatever you say that stuff your
voice sounds like how come I didn't get
it
did I bet you there's Parts in Nevada
you could buy for like five bucks dude
like five bucks an acre yeah you know
like there's nothing there the only bad
thing is you have to like flatten it out
but actually if there's terrain it could
be like better yeah you know what the
cottage four the cost goes up the more
stuff you want to put on it I have a
buddy who tried to do that and even to
connect his land to the road way more
than the land itself to build the
infrastructure just to get a runner go
and do it yeah I don't want to talk
about that I know this is real like
adult [ __ ] huh back to the alien dick
foreign
[Music]